I always go back to this idea of so many
of the problems in the world and whether
it's uh Bitcoin maximalist or a uh kind
of uh fed critics or whoever they all
kind of arrive at the same conclusion
which is uh we don't have free markets
and free markets have kind of been uh
co-opted
um and taken over by ideologies by uh uh
these social focuses by uh everything
other than like free market capitalism
right and if you believe in free markets
and their ability to self-correct and
kind of eventually find the answer uh
optimizing for anything other than let
the free market do its thing uh is
obviously intervention and would prevent
the free market from from operating and
so
what I think is a unique uh way to
present Bitcoin or other types of
Technologies uh that follows them or eat
those is that it's trying to implement
free market dynamics again but do it in
a way where they cannot be co-opted like
yes somebody can go and manipulate the
Bitcoin price right by if you're just a
large holder or whatever but they cannot
change fundamentally what Bitcoin is
they cannot take over the network they
cannot change the programmatic monetary
policy they cannot do these things and
so it goes back to like the classic
Google like don't be evil can't be evil
right type uh uh nomenclature
if we were successful in implementing
free markets where people could not take
them over would the world be a better
place it's Up For Debate but I think
there's a strong argument that the free
market oh yeah definitely leave yourself
correct okay so let's say that I
probably I probably agree with almost
you know with much of that right
the only thing is
um
do you know the difference between open
loop versus closed loop control no
okay so like in control theory
um let's say that you uh you had a car
okay and uh you close your eyes and you
just hit the gas okay that's like open
loop control there's no feedback okay
but closed loop control you have your
eyes open and you're looking at the road
and you're making micro Corrections and
steering the wheel left and right and
and so on and so forth and so you're
making micro Corrections
um constantly sometimes a little bit
left sometimes a little bit right and uh
and that's keeping you on the straight
narrow to get there and if it's a
complicated and long Direction
um
you can't just
keep thing veering left or keep the
thing veering right and hope to get
there okay
um as as a second metaphor that I think
is also related imagine that somebody
was a westist why are they a westist
because they liked the idea of
California
okay so you just kept going west
and they then they got to California and
then they they had people in the group
say we have to keep going west what are
you some kind of cuck you don't want to
be you know we got to keep going west
aren't you at West is right you're going
east now you're in California and so
then they keep going west they land
Pacific Ocean okay and so the point is
that an ideology that is just a
Direction
is going to insist on a purity that is
actually a stupidity because you really
want to optimize for Destination not
consistent Direction
you can go too far left you can go too
far right you have to actually be able
to steer and so it may be the case that
at this point in time I agree that one
should see your right or steer left or
or up or down or something else right
like there's more than just two two
directions also but you have to have
some vision of what that destination is
and moreover as you know as a startup
investor just the words that somebody
writes in a slide deck there's a
thousand micro Corrections that they
have to make on the steering wheel ten
thousand hundred thousand between that
slide deck their words and their vision
and their actual destination you know
and so simply saying it on the Internet
it's like you know it's it's a starting
place
but the execution the implementation of
that concept require many pragmatic
compromises with reality and so that's
actually one of the things I talk about
in the book is basically I do believe in
moral entrepreneurship in the sense that
I do believe people should uh and I
think Tech entrepreneurs have actually
only done this implicitly it's not just
about a technological innovation it's
about a moral Innovation it's not just
about a failure in the market it's a
failure in society that one wants to fix
you don't just have something that is a
better mousetrap you have something
that's a better world but how do you
actually prove that that's actually a
good moral Innovation and not a bad one
because just like most tech companies
fail you know uh most most you know
things don't actually work in the market
many moral Innovations like the
Communists had a moral Innovation which
is profit bad The Profit used to be
considered good then they said hey let's
what happens if we say profit is bad it
turned out to be a very bad uh door to
go down but hundreds of millions of
people were enslaved 100 million died
before you fix that right other moral
Innovations like you know cigarettes bad
or smoking bad you know before
cigarettes are acceptable or even good
then flip to bad I argue there's
probably on balance a good intervention
and then yet still others like
prohibition which said alcohol bad and
then it got flipped back to alcohol
acceptable right that was you know
neutral to negative that the prohibition
thing but you can also argue that
alcohol does cause still a lot of crimes
DUI Etc so you can argue that point
maybe you want not a coercive
prohibition but a dry Society You could
argue that point okay so the thing is if
you have a moral Innovation if you have
a strong moral position then what you
want to do and I talk about this in the
book is build society as a service right
prove that you're right by actually
going let's see your Maximus you go and
build your Citadel and you you bring
people in society is a service and the
thousand things that can't fit in a
tweet all the decisions that you
actually have to make about a real
Society like what are the laws going to
be are there going to be police
um is there going to be any central
government of any kind all this type of
stuff you actually will have to go and
figure out out in your society as a
service and it'll help you make
pragmatic concessions to reality that
one does not if one is just you know
kind of popping off right and that's
kind of how I think about it is you want
to give people the ability to morally
innovate and technologically innovate
they build these societies as services
and the way that there's a check on
their legitimacy is that people choose
to come and they choose to stay and if
they don't like it they can choose to
leave and they can choose between others
of these kinds and uh you know they can
tour it online that's why the digital
component is so important they can tour
it online cheaply so they can go in
comparison shop and then find the best
ones but with that said I do think
there's a big difference between those
folks who will build these societies and
those folks who are the consumer you
know citizens I do think there's a good
thing about comparison shopping between
jurisdictions but that's like you know
the difference between buying an iPhone
building an iPhone is much harder and so
the folks who are going to build these
jurisdictions cannot simply be the
consumer citizen they have to be you
have to be much more missionary than
quote unquote you know mercenary right
um so this is how I think you can
actually prove that your online morality
is Right build a society oriented around
that see what it actually looks like
when you materialize it just like a
theory theory of you know math or
computer science you actually sometimes
need to write the code to see if it
works and then you can show that it's
attractive and you've actually made the
right trade-offs or it might be
something that only works when you can
be you know in the back road throwing
stones or online throwing stones and it
doesn't work if you actually go and
declare yourself president of Historic
Society and try and build one